PROFESSOR: So let's
go through, now,
how we can parameterize
our guideline specifically
for COVID-19 by looking at
specific superspreading events.
So the event that was analyzed
in great detail first,
and which is going to
be of most use for us
initially for parameterizing
the guideline,
is the Skajit Valley Chorale
superspreading incident.
So this was, again, a 2
and 1/2 hour choir practice
involving 61 people, one of
whom was known to be infected.
The practice lasted
2 and 1/2 hours.
And in the end, there were 53
infected people, two of whom
later died.
So this was a large room with
a height of 4 and 1/2 meters
and an area of 180
meters squared.
It was poorly ventilated.
The heat was on for a
certain amount of time
and then taken off.
And the average air change rate
was estimated at 0.65 per hour.
And of course, the people were
singing for much of the time,
leading to much higher
rates of droplet emission.
And in fact, I think we can
assume for this event, given
the huge number
of infections that
occurred in such a short
time, that the index patient--
the index case-- was at
near the peak viral load,
peak of infection.
And also, that allows us to
make a conservative estimate
of using that for
calibrating our guideline.
So if we look at
the figure here,
we can see the
droplet distributions
taken from experimental
measurements
of Morawska et al in 2009.
And those droplet distributions
have been fed into the model
that we just described
and evolved in time
in such a way that corresponds
to the conditions of the Skajit
Valley Choir itself.
And so what we can see is
that the droplet distribution
corresponding to singing--
or the closest
approximation of singing,
which are measurements
of voiced aahs
from the original experiment--
that distribution is much
bigger than all the others.
It has a very broad tail
to somewhat larger sizes.
But it has a peak
just below 1 micron.
Similarly, the other
types of activities
measured in the
original study, which
correspond to, for example,
whispered ahh or speaking
or in counting of
numbers, for example,
or various forms of breathing
through the nose and the mouth
or only through the nose--
all those distributions have
much lower sort of magnitude
or number of drops.
And this is also drop volume.
We have accounted for the
size of the drops as well.
So it's the total droplet volume
per total volume or volume
fraction.
And the peak of all
the distributions
is in a similar place,
just below 1 micron,
so again, corresponding
to the aerosol range.
And it's important that we take
those droplet distributions
and evolve them in the
Skajit Valley Choir space.
So then, we can figure out
which of those droplets
survived and would be in the air
and would be then corresponding
to the airborne
transmission and can
be compared with the actual
spreading events that occurred
using the Wells-Riley model.
So is it a short amount of time?
We're going to assume there was
no delay caused by incubation.
But rather, people were getting
infected but not passing it
on to anybody else.
And so we will use
the Wells-Riley model.
So when we do that
fitting, we come out
with a value of Cq, the number
of infection quanta per volume
in the exhaled breath
of the infected person,
around 900 quanta
per meter cubed.
A published study
of Miller et al
came to a similar conclusion
of 870 quanta per meters cubed.
And so we can take that to be
a reasonable value for singing.
Now, if we go to
the next figure,
we can include all of these
estimated total quanta
concentrations corresponding
to different hypothetical forms
of respiration in the
Skajit Valley Choir
and use that for rescaling.
So we can say, the choir was
actually involving singing.
And that gave us a
number around 900.
And then if we rescale,
the other amounts
of respiratory
droplets corresponding
to different activities would
have correspondingly scaled
values of Cq.
And as a further calibration,
we can compare it
with another recent study
of Asadi and Ristenpart,
where again, different types
of respiratory activities
were measured for their
aerosol size distributions,
including speaking at
different levels of volume
and also breathing
in different ways.
And if we line up
two values that
correspond to sort of
intermediate speech
as a calibration, then
we find that the quanta
values that we infer--
the Cq values-- for both of
those independent studies
of respiratory droplets
really correlate nicely
across different
types of activities
from breathing to
speaking to singing,
allowing us a consistent
definition of Cq,
again, for a situation
corresponding
to most likely peak infectivity.
So we are talking about
sort of the worst case
scenario in order to derive
a conservative guideline.
It should also be noted that the
median age of the choir members
was 69.
And by using this
spreading incident,
we are again being conservative,
because it is well established
that elderly persons have an
elevated risk of complications
and even death from
COVID-19, and perhaps also
some evidence showing
increased risk of transmission.
So therefore, when we
apply the guideline
to a general
population, including
younger and healthy
people, that we
will find that we are making
a conservative estimate,
which is our goal.
So at this point, we have a
fully parameterized guideline.
And we have consistent
values of Cq
across a range of
respiratory activities
involving two different studies
of respiratory aerosols,
all coming from the
Skajit Choir incident.
So now, let's look at some
other spreading incidents
to see if we can get
consistent values of Cq
in cases where people
were not singing
and where the size of
the room was different,
and sort of see
if we really have
a transferable inference here.
And if we do find
consistent numbers,
it provides further
evidence to support
the hypothesis of
airborne transmission
in all of these cases.
So the next example
we'll look at
is the incident of the Tiantong
Temple religious ceremony
and, in particular, the buses
that went back and forth
from that ceremony.
One bus, in particular, was
similar to this Dongfeng tour
bus luxury liner,
which underwent
a 100-minute trip to Ningbo and
then back in the same seating.
The bus had seating for 68,
or had 68 persons in it.
The total time was 1.7 hours.
And the one infected
person managed
to infect around 21
others, when we account
for some that may have been
infected at the event, given
the low rate of infection to
people outside of the bus.
Using those numbers
and taking into
account the size of
the bus and the fact
that there was no
forced ventilation--
this was a winter ride.
And there was only
natural ventilation--
and if we use a value
that's been measured
for other types of
public transit buses
where no forced
ventilation is occurring,
then we conclude that
the Cq for this event
is around 72 quanta
per meter cubed, which
is a very consistent estimate
with what we obtained before
for a situation where
people are perhaps speaking
in an intermediate tone on
a noisy bus over that period
of time.
It's also important to
note that a recent analysis
of the incident
involving interviews
of all the people involved
established that there
was no correlation between
the position of a person
with respect to the infected
person in the seating
chart of the bus relative
to whether they got infected
or not.
So in other words, it was
not short-range transmission
through puffs or
respiratory jets.
But instead somehow,
there was a circulation
throughout the bus of
infected air as the most
plausible explanation.
Our third example is
the Diamond Princess.
So this was the
quarantined cruise ship
in Yokohama Port, Japan.
There were 3,011 passengers
and crew onboard.
And the quarantine
lasted for 12 days,
or around 288 hours, at which
point people began to leave.
And we won't use any
data from that point.
The quarantine is a
good chance for us
to study airborne transmission,
because people were largely
confined to their room.
So of course, some of the crew
were going back and forth,
bringing food and checking
on the passengers.
But the vast majority of
people were essentially
cooped up in their room
with their fellow travelers
or family members
in small groups,
typically with the windows
closed because this
was in the winter,
and with ventilation
which was doing a significant
amount of recirculation
between the rooms.
And in fact,
transmission occurred
across different
rooms, where people
did not have direct contact
with a known infected person
and yet still managed
to get infected.
In those 12 days, the number
of infections grew very rapidly
and, in fact, had sort of
an exponential increase.
So in the end, there
were 354 infected persons
when they began releasing
passengers after 12 days.
And the fact that the shape of
the infections versus time is
an increasing exponential-like
curve suggests that this cannot
be modeled by the Wells-Riley
equation, where instead,
the number of infected people
has to saturate as you run out
of susceptibles.
So this acceleration
of the number
of infected people with time is
best attributed to incubation.
And it is known that the
incubation time for COVID-19
is around 5.5 days.
Some people may
have been infected,
and likely were infected, before
the start of the quarantine.
So there definitely
were infected people
generating newly infectious
people during the time
of the quarantine.
So as a simple analysis of
this incident, we can use--
or let us use--
our model for fast incubation.
We have an analytical solution
for the trend in the number
of cases versus time.
And as you can
see in the figure,
this model has a pretty
good fit to the growth
in the number of cases.
And if we fit that model and
infer what is the value of Cq,
then we come out with a
number around 30 quanta
per meter cubed, again,
very consistent with all
the other inferences and
basically consistent with light
activity, light normal speech,
and sort of resting breathing
that was going on in the ship.
Now, there definitely could
be some debate over the way
that we've just analyzed the
ship, in the sense that we
had analyzed it
from the perspective
of a well-mixed ship.
So we're assuming that the
infectious aerosols were spread
throughout the ship uniformly.
So that is obviously a
gross estimate, very crude.
On the other hand, we get
a very reasonable result.
And there is evidence that
transmission was occurring
through the vents, through the
hallways, and through the air
to large numbers of people.
And so the fact that we get a
reasonably consistent number
of 30 quanta per
meter cubed compared
to all of our other
estimates does
support the idea of airborne
transmission occurring
in a somewhat uniform
and well-mixed fashion
across the ship.
Yet another inference
we could make
would be to look at
the initial spreading
of the epidemic in Wuhan, China,
where it first originated.
So there have been
a number of studies
of the initial spreading.
And the reproductive
number of the spreading
of the disease, R0, has been
estimated to be around 3.5.
In fact, there's a
range of estimates
from that time period, given the
sort of somewhat limited data.
But that's the agreed
upon average number.
Now, there is an
interesting thought exercise
we can do looking at that
number if we make the assumption
that the majority
of transmissions
occurred indoors, in people's
family homes or apartments.
So if we take the time
period for the spreading
of the infection in our
analysis to be 5.5 days, which
is the average
incubation time, and we
use the average size
of a Chinese household
in that region of
3.03 people, and we
assume an average size of a
Chinese apartment for that size
family of 90 meters
cubed, and we also
assume measured typical
natural ventilation
rates for this time of winter
of around 0.3 per hour,
or a 3-hour air change
time roughly, then
interestingly enough,
from that analysis,
we find Cq again is
30 quanta per meter
cubed, the same as
the number that we
got for the Diamond Princess.
So again, this is a
very crude estimate.
This analysis is even more crude
than the analysis of the ship.
We're looking at the entire
population of a city.
And we're assuming that
the spreading is happening
in people's homes when
they spend time together
for long periods of time,
sharing indoor air which
is typically not
very well ventilated,
and not wearing
masks, importantly.
So at that time,
people were absolutely
wearing masks outside the house.
And in fact, for
much of that time,
people were confined
to their apartments
even under threat of force
from the authorities.
So people were definitely
spending a lot of time
in their homes with
their families.
And it's interesting to observe
that despite that quarantine
that the spreading still
occurred fairly rapidly.
And it occurred
in a way which is
consistent with indoor
transmission in people's homes.
So if we take all
of this analysis
and come back to our
figure of Cq values--
again, that's the number
of infection quanta
per meter cubed
of exhaled breath
for an infected individual--
then we can put our inferences
for the Ningbo bus, the Diamond
Princess, and the Wuhan
outbreak on the same plot
as the values we inferred by
rescaling the value of 900
for the Skajit Valley Chorale.
And what we find, again,
is a very consistent set
of estimates over a range of
respiratory activities, which
tells us that the Cq is around
on the order of 10 or so,
or tens, for light activity
and resting breathing.
It's in the range of 10 to
100, or maybe several hundred,
for speech at different
levels of volume,
which roughly-- the
number of droplets
is known to increase roughly
linearly with the decibel level
of speech.
And then singing has a more--
obviously a much, much
greater release of
particles and aerosols.
And that's at a much higher
level, in the many hundreds.
So I think those are fairly
consistent numbers, which
again, looking at most of
these cases, are conservative
and could be applied
in the guideline
to a wide range of
examples involving
other types of populations,
which may be healthier,
younger, less
likely to transmit,
compared to all of these
super spreading incidents.